l'archipel est une unité qui accueille
des filles de 11 à 17 ans dans un grand
centre pour jeunes de la dpj où l'on
utilise beaucoup beaucoup de style au
ces des stylos des crayons feutres
d'écrivain est face à moi aussi je lance
du beau faire on faire quelque chose je
connais personne cyclage moi je t'ai pas
au jeu n'est pas belle mais thierry
massé dans le recyclage
ce qui n'est pas vraiment comme ça se
pratique mais pas de cette façon là
voici donc les boîtes créées par les
jeunes pour que tous les stylos se
retrouve sur la bonne voie de recyclage
moi je suis bien kaki 11 en mars et
maria puis j'ai 14 ans pour que toutes
les unités de l'établissement participe
à l'effort
il fallait faire connaître le projet on
voulait aller présenter en vrai mais
comme on trouvait pas à cause d'un coded
fait là on s'est dit mais une vidéo ça
peut être le fun ce pas trop sérieux non
plus j'ai pensé que c'était une bonne
idée de faire comme un bulletin nouvelle
est créée comme professionnels qui ont
un traitement net com - ouais c'est vrai
que c'est une bonne idée
bonjour et bienvenue au déneigement de
marche
c'était l'arrivée et en sortie au pied
tout un groupe qui ont réfléchi à leur
scénario
mais déjà il y avait choisi ddd lieu sur
le site qui pouvait s'apparenter un
studio par exemple de nouvelles au fer
l'un à l'extérieur de passe sur la rue
tout ça ça venait vraiment de leur
imagination m pendant le montage du
genre caroil nul elle a ajouté le petit
le petit logo comme le journal de
chambly le téléjournal c'est ça que ça
faisait déjà un peu plus et c'était
comme un peu plus réaliste j'étais la
personne qui avait vu la requête dans le
fond mais c'est ça qui avait vu le
mauvais geste jette un crime le champion
moi je le réussis de rajouter comme un
peu d'humour parce qu'on n'était pas
comme c'est pas comme si je résultat une
nouvelle si on faisait ça pour le fun
les projets de recyclage des stylos et
de vidéos ont fait du bien après un
printemps des routes en début c'était
très difficile parce que vu que c'était
nouveau
toutes les mesures ont été mises en
place comme créé sévèrement ici au
centre fait c'était très difficile je
peux par ma famille mais il y avait
comme plus d'école plus à crier
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
essaie de travailler l'estiment de swat
on s'entend là-dessus c'est un défi
constant avec mon genre les éducatrices
de l'archipel croit avoir trouvé une
façon de répondre aux intérêts de six
jeunes filles en abordant un thème par
mois depuis l'automne nous on a parlé de
féministes pendant un mois on a parlé de
anti racistes pendant un mois
c'est tout des sujets qui venait des
recettes et à leurs propositions
ça a eu cet effet la deûle ermotti reid
une étincelle dans la vie de six jeunes
filles et dans les yeux de leurs
éducatrices on s'aperçoit que c'est des
gens qui sont allumés qui veulent
s'engager ils veulent en apprendre plus
c'est le fun de voir à quel point
justement être déploient leurs forces
dans ce projet là parce que c'est sur
c'est ça notre vrai salaire en fait
on pensait mettre une boîte au début
puis on est rendu à cette bois fakher
oui je serai prête à recommencer alors
wifi songe déjà aux prochains bulletins
de nouvelles
merci c'était tout pour ce soir une
bonne soirée ici anne louise despatie
radio canada mon frère